according to the latest cbs news poll
more than 70 percent of americans
believe democracy in the united states
is under threat and more than half of
them believe political violence across
the country will increase cbs news
elections and surveys director anthony
salvanto is here he's the guy that puts
the poll together then tells us what
exactly americans told us good to see
you again this morning in person uh
president biden gave that big speech
last week suggesting democracy is under
threat and our numbers suggest he may be
on to something right well the concern
is out there ed take a look at the
number who say they think political
violence will increase and not only is
it two-thirds but that has been itself
increasing more people worried about
that though i should say both parties
say this is not a good thing that that
is a bad thing and then we ask look
ahead for the next generation and a
majority thinks the us will be less of a
democracy going forward so yeah the
concern's out there but you know both
parties blame each other for it right
democrats and republicans both a bit
strident about each other yeah you know
this is a really important measure going
forward when we ask democrats how do you
see republicans look across the other
side well okay about half of them call
them the opposition that's somebody you
can go back and forth with on policy but
almost half of them call them enemies
that's an existential threat and then
same thing goes when you ask republicans
what do you think about democrats
opposition yeah half of them but have
them call them enemies and this is so
important because it tells you this is
going to be an election not just about a
fight over public policy but over the
other side's motivations and the perhaps
silver lining in this is it's half
of republicans half of democrats feel
that way so only about a third of the
country really is feeling that way about
the other side that is such an important
point still a big number but not as big
as people may worry it is not everybody
there's independents there's half of
partisans who don't see the world this
way but oftentimes these folks drive the
conversation they're the more
ideological folks some of the the mega
republicans who call themselves mega
republicans are more likely to be in
this camp of seeing the other side as
enemies but it's not everybody ed and
there is some good news in the survey uh
in terms of what might be coming next
yeah you know people do worry that
there's going to be a politicized
election counting process officials may
not certify votes so this may go on past
november in some sense at least people
worry that's not great here's the good
news that's not good but here's where we
find young people more optimistic that
americans can work out their differences
and that's where we find the bright spot
in all this maybe in the future we get
past a lot we also just need them to
show up to vote and they need members
exactly anthony salvanto who does
polling for us here at cbs we thank you
david
we we can work out our differences yes
we can nice to hear